the tiny South Pacific island of
Pentecost is home to what may be the
most dangerous test of faith in the
world every year village elders
organized a ritual designed to secure
the God's favor in a spectacular
insightful display called land of young
men and boys some just five years old
literally risk their necks only to
fragile vines save them from crashing
into the jetty it's the ancient
precursor of bungee jump but here it's
considered a sacrifice for the survival
of the community chief Willie Orion
vivek presides over his villages
ceremony the windy climb on a tower they
have no fear because it's definitely the
man stay healthy to put appear out and
then he must jump he must take a lecture
by some estimates land diving dates back
15 centuries its exact origin is obscure
but it is tied to the local religion of
animism people here believe in a world
of spirits that demands offerings
originally divers would perform just
after the yam harvest to thank the gods
and to assure another fruitful crop
[Music]
the village of wali is one of several on
the island that holds land diving
rituals every April of name Willie
Warren supervises the towers
construction and to add to his place by
jump day nine men have volunteered the
down a vine brace but this diver is
lucky in the past a snap vine resulted
in a fractured hip others have broken
collarbones
[Music]
[Applause]
traditionally Islanders believe that the
higher the jump the greater the blessing
men brave enough to die from the top
secured a good yam crop and the
prosperity of the community Willie
Warren is one of their best landowners
he gets a raucous welcome
Willie must jump out as far as he can to
avoid impaling himself on the towers
rough wads he urges on the singers
summoning support Willie proves why he
is a land dive champion he's strong
enough to spring back on his feet an
accomplishment few can match it's a
performance worthy of the gods and a
personal test of strength bravery and
faith